>> Larry: YES!
THANK YOU VERY MUCH!
WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
I'M YOUR HOST, LARRY WILMORE,
THAT'S ME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BIG NEWS FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
NOW WE ALL KNOW WE GAVE UP ON
HOPE A LONG TIME AGO, BUT
POTENTIAL CHANGE WITH CUBA MAY
BE ABOUT TO HAPPEN.
>> REPRESENTATIVES MET IN HAVANA
TO DISCUSS REESTABLISHING
DIPLOMATIC TIES BETWEEN THE TWO
COUNTRIES.
AN AGREEMENT WOULD ULTIMATELY
LIFT TRADE AND TRAVEL EMBARGOS
IN PLACE FOR SOME 50 YEARS.
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: THIS IS REALLY GOOD
NEWS.
THOSE AREN'T REALLY GOOD CIGARS,
THOUGH
CUBA.
THAT'S RIGHT.
TODAY, FOR THE FIRST TIME IN A
GENERATION, THE U.S. AND CUBA
ARE HOLDING HIGH-LEVEL
DIPLOMATIC TALKS IN PUBLIC.
AND LIKE SEX IN A HATCHBACK,
THINGS ARE OFF TO A ROUGH START.
>> THE HEAD OF CUBA'S TEAM,
FOREIGN MINISTERY OFFICIAL
JOSEFINA VIDAL , CRITICIZED THE
CUBAN ADJUSTMENT ACT, WHICH
INCLUDES THE WET FOOT/DRY FOOT
POLICY.
IT STATES THAT CUBANS
INTERCEPTED AT SEA BY U.S. LAW
ENFORCEMENT ARE RETURNED TO
CUBA, WHILE THOSE WHO MAKE IT TO
U.S. SOIL CAN APPLY FOR
PERMANENT RESIDENCY AFTER ONE
YEAR.
>> Larry: SO IF YOU GET TO
LAND, YOU CAN STAY?
BUT IF YOU GET CAUGHT ON THE
WATER, YOU'RE OUT?
MAN, THAT'S SOME HIGH-STAKES
MARCO POLO.
MARCO!
"YOU ARE UNDER ARREST!"
POLO.
NOW AMERICA IS EASING
RESTRICTIONS ON CUBAN TRAVEL,
AND COMMERCIAL AIRLINES LIKE
DELTA AND JETBLUE HAVE ALREADY
SHOWN INTEREST IN ROUTES TO
HAVANA.
NO WORD YET IF SPIRIT AIRLINES
IS GOING TO GET IN ON THE
ACTION, BUT IN ALL HONESTY,
SERIOUSLY, YOU WOULD BE
BETTER OFF ON A DAMN RAFT.
SORRY SPIRIT.
NOW, BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T HAD
RELATIONS WITH CUBA IN SO LONG,
I THINK WE NEED TO DO A LITTLE
CATCHING UP.
SO HERE TO TAKE US THROUGH THAT
IS OUR OWN RICKY VELEZ.
RICKY, WELCOME.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
NOW, YOU'RE CUBAN, RIGHT RICKY?
>> NAH, HALF PUERTO RICAN, HALF
IRISH.
>> Larry: CLOSE ENOUGH.
ALL RIGHT.
BREAK IT DOWN FOR US.
>> LARRY, I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW SERIOUS OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH CUBA IS.
LET'S START WITH THE CUBAN
MISSILE CRISIS.
IT WAS LIKE BACK IN THE '50s
OR '60s, I'M NOT SURE
MISSILES WERE FLYING AT CUBA.
AND MAGNETO WAS DOWN THERE AND
WAS, LIKE, NO THANKS!
AND THE NEXT THING YOU KNOW,
PROFESSOR X IS SHOT IN THE BACK.
NOW HE'S GOT TO BE IN A
WHEELCHAIR. IT'S ALL MESSED UP
>> Larry: RICKY -- THIS HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH CUBA.
THIS SOUNDS LIKE X-MEN FIRST
CLASS.
>> DO YOU WANT ME TO FILE MY
REPORT OR NOT, LARRY?
>> Larry: OF COURSE.
SURE.
GO AHEAD.
>> SO THEN AFTER THAT MISSILE
BUSINESS, AMERICA'S, LIKE,
"WE'RE NOT TALKING TO YOU
ANYMORE, CUBA.
BYE, BITCH!"
THAT WAS THAT.
BUT THAT'S THE '60s.
NOW WE'RE IN THE '70s.
NEXT THING YOU KNOW, MICHAEL
CORELEONE  GOES DOWN THERE TO
CONFRONT FREDO BECAUSE HE KNOWS
WHAT HE DID.
SO MICHAEL SAYS, "YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO DIE IN A BOAT."
BAM.
'80s.
>> Larry: WAIT A MINUTE.
I THINK YOU'RE STILL TALKING
ABOUT MOVIES.
>> YEAH...
DOCUMENTARIES.
CAN I FINISH?
>> Larry: YES, PLEASE.
FINISH.
I CAN'T WAIT TO HEAR WHAT
HAPPENS.
>> SO THEN AL PACINO'S SO BUMMED
ABOUT SHOOTING HIS BROTHER, HE
GETS ALL TONY MONTANA AND HE'S
LIKE "FIRST YOU GOTTA GET THE
MONEY, THEN YOU GOTTA GET THE
POWER, THEN YOU GOTTA GET THE
WOMEN." SO THEN IT'S, LIKE, "SAY
HELLO TO MY LITTLE FRIEND."
AND THEN HE'S LIKE "SAY HELLO TO
MY LITTLE FRIEND!"
(BULLETS FIRING)
FLASH 30 YEARS FORWARD.
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE WITH CUBA
NOW. YOU KNOW.
>> Larry: RICKEY, THAT WASN'T
REMOTELY HELPFUL.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME, LARRY.
I'M JUST TRYING TO KEEP IT
100 LIKE YOU, MAN
>> Larry: RICKY VELEZ!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
THANK YOU, RICKY!
ALL RIGHT, LET'S SEE IF I CAN
TRY TO EXPLAIN IT
YOU KNOW WHO CUBA IS TO US?
YOU KNOW THAT UNCLE THAT YOUR
PARENTS HAD A FALLING OUT WITH,
LIKE, 50 YEARS AGO, AND NOBODY
KNOWS WHAT REALLY HAPPENED?
RUMORS ARE MY DAD TRIED TO KILL
HIM A COUPLE OF TIMES, BUT HE'S
GOT THIS REALLY COOL BEACH HOUSE
RIGHT DOWN THE STREET.
YOU SEE THESE OLD PICTURES OF
THE CRAZY PARTIES HE USED TO
HAVE WITH, LIKE, SINATRA AND
HEMINGWAY HANGING OUT.
HE'S GOT ALL THESE '59 CHEVYS.
AND YOU WERE JUST DYING TO VISIT
HIM, AND YOUR DAD'S, LIKE, "NO!"
WELL, NOW HE'S SAYING, "WE'LL
SEE."
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE WITH CUBA.
THE TRUTH IS, I DON'T REALLY
KNOW ABOUT CUBA.
WHAT'S IT LIKE TO LIVE THERE
THESE DAYS?
>> THEY DON'T JUST GO TO A
GROCERY STORE.
THEY HAVE WHAT'S CALLED A
LIBERETTA WHERE THEY DO THE
RATIONS.
SO LET'S SAY YOU'RE A FAMILY OF
FIVE, YOU GET ONE CHICKEN A
MONTH.
>> Larry: ONE CHICKEN A MONTH?
MAN, THAT'S HORRIBLE!
HERE WE USE A CHICKEN AS BREAD!
(APPLAUSE)
WE ARE SUCH ASSHOLES.
(LAUGHTER)
ACTUALLY, I WOULDN'T MIND
DOUBLING DOWN RIGHT NOW.
MUST RESIST AMERICAN STOMACH.
WELL, IT CAN'T GET MUCH WORSE
THAN THAT.
>> EVEN WHEN YOU GET INTERNET,
IT'S SO SLOW YOU USE IT TO HAVE
MAIL.
MAYBE ONCE A MONTH OR ONCE A
WEEK, YOU GO TO Facebook TO
SEE YOUR FRIENDS.
THAT'S OUR INTERNET.
>> Larry: ONCE A MONTH?
THAT PLACE IS A HELL HOLE.
GOD, I'M SO ANGRY.
SHOW ME THAT DOUBLE DOWN AGAIN?
MMM...
THANKS, DOUBLE DOWN.
WELL, THIS IS REALLY TERRIBLE.
SO I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
ANYBODY WOULD BE AGAINST LIFTING
THESE SANCTIONS.
>> THE CUBAN GOVERNMENT IN
EXCHANGE FOR ALL OF THESE
CONCESSIONS THAT THE WHITE HOUSE
HAS NOW MADE HAS SAID NOTHING OR
DONE NOTHING TO ADVANCE
DEMOCRACY, NO FREEDOM OF THE
PRESS, NO FREEDOM OF
ORGANIZATION, THERE WILL BE NO
ELECTION.
>> Larry: WELL, HE MAKES A
GOOD POINT.
WE DON'T LIKE DOING BUSINESS
WITH COUNTRIES THAT DON'T HAVE
FREE SPEECH OR ELECTIONS.
UNLESS THEY'RE MAKING OUR
iPhones.
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
OH, THE TRUTH, OH THE TRUTH.
THIS IS CONFUSING.
BOTH SIDES HAVE GOOD POINTS.
LOOK, IF WE WANT TO USE OUR
MONEY TO HELP REVITALIZE A PLACE
THAT'S FROZEN IN TIME WITH OLD
CARS AND ABANDONED FACTORIES,
LET'S JUST GO TO DETROIT.
(LAUGHTER)
RIGHT?
BUT IF BY OUR PRESENCE WE CAN
ULTIMATELY HELP IMPROVE THE WAY
OF LIFE FOR AN OPPRESSED PEOPLE,
EVEN IF IT MEANS THAT FOR NOW
THEY JUST GET A TASTE OF
FREEDOM, I'M OKAY GOING TO CUBA.
AND I'M NOT MAD IF THAT TASTE OF
FREEDOM COMES IN THE FORM OF A
DOUBLE DOWN.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.